[Music]
but og were a team that came through
obviously had their roster ripped apart
by evil geniuses
and i learned that the two players are
leaving and one of them's my best friend
we spent eight years together and now
it's over so forming a team
three months before ti
and having a shot at winning ti no i
just want to own some noobs
wake up in the morning and that's just
it yeah
[Applause]
you had this infinite source of
motivation no it's not there anymore but
the way i see it is that it's still
there
he just does not give a crap anna will
give all the light this is just fountain
farming
is it almost
[Applause]
his lifetime
[Music]
i take offense from teams thinking
they can win against us as that'll be it
no more backup here for ogs tundra
they'll claim the victory gg called by
og tundra will take this series 2-0 and
they've secured themselves a ticket to
the grand final here i i think they're a
very arrogant team actually and i don't
respect arrogance at all so i can't
really respect who they are as a team
thing is you win as a team and you lose
as a team and
everything that we're gonna do here
we're gonna do as a team
og were once the plucky underdog heroes
of dota congratulations again your
champions team oh gee
if you somehow don't already know their
story og started as a small independent
org founded by the players who climbed
their way up the ranks of the
competitive dodo ladder through
devastating losses and roster shuffles i
just want to own some noobs
wake up in the morning and that's just
that's it yeah
after a few years they became known for
dominating dota's majors winning more
major titles than any other team in the
world despite that though dota's real
prize the aegis was always just out of
og's reach but even without doda's
biggest prize og had already won
something else they had the hearts of
fans all over the world individual team
members most notably no tail were heavy
fan favorites oh gee were all about the
power of flowers and friendship they
were the underdogs that you just felt
compelled to root for as a pro player i
look at some teams like when they're
performing their best i think it's magic
i think it's incredible i think it's
like a miracle that you have five
individuals like coming together like
this sometimes it doesn't always work
out sometimes you have people like a bit
out of sync not on the same page
it's just important to remember that
everybody is trying their best but
despite their best efforts after years
of underperforming a ti and a mad
scramble to even have a team ready in
time for the tournament ti8 seemed
completely out of og's grasp but
shockingly they blew everyone away and
became the first team in the history of
dota 2 to win ti from the open qualifier
and anybody who thought that og would be
satisfied with just one ti win was in
for a pretty rude awakening the next
year why should you become weaker from
doing this once you can stamp it again
because you're satisfied with yourself
because you're satisfied so you're weak
now
you had this infinite source of
motivation no it's not there anymore you
know but the way i see it is that it's
still there og rolled into ti9 with the
kind of swagger that you can only
justify if you're the best team in the
world they took luffy pictures played
insane comps and even trolled their
opponents in game thompson he just does
not give a crap anna will give all the
life this is just fountain bombing
gee you got it this is soul breaking
[Applause]
jj okay
[Laughter]
and it turns out that all that posturing
was justified og could back it all up
because at ti-9 they became the first
team to not only win two tis but to win
two tis in a row there is no question
that we are witnessing the best team of
all time
i'm i'm at a loss of words from the way
that they played this it was just an
absolute beatdown they just
they're just way too good at dota but
this was where the trouble started
og had reached the pinnacle of glory in
dota 2. no tale had officially become
the richest esports player in the world
seb got one of the sickest caster calls
in history dedicated to him
[Applause]
finally got to retire in peace while
anna actually came out of retirement to
relive his glory days and play with og
and the team now had an exciting new
player in their midst saxa johan tell me
what did you see in him
uh someone tall just kidding
at first things looked pretty good for
og except they weren't doing as well as
you'd think for the former ti champions
og failed to qualify for the singapore
major and the wii play animator they pot
the god strength but of course the
refraction is allowing him to ignore all
of that damage and kill some spiders but
that's all he's going to be killing here
the mother
mother comes as always team liquid
no tails dead midford's dead insert hero
here dead they're in the bat yeah yeah
wow okay
all right they're hungry anna decided
retirement was the way to go after all
and dipped after just a couple months on
the roster forcing og to look for a
replacement before the ti western
european regional qualifiers started
they found their man in sumail so things
looked okay on that front but was og
okay in the months leading up to ti
there were a few things going on with og
no tail publicly accused another team of
cheating before getting the full story
on what the tournament rules permitted
seb jumped in on that one as well before
getting distracted by a public feud with
team secret social media manager arno
who was admittedly a little too happy
about og's lackluster performances the
result of course was a barrage of dms in
which seb chastised afno in a pretty
caustic way for allegedly taking things
too far all things considered secret
social media guy may have had a reason
to act the way he did given that seb
called secret arrogant for even thinking
they were on og's level in an interview
he gave ruha back in 2020. i i think
they're very arrogant team
actually and i don't respect argans at
all so i can't really respect who they
are as a team
and they're trying to act like they look
confident and i truly believe that when
somebody's confident you feel it and i
don't feel confidence from them a lot of
people found the combination of what seb
said and how he said it ironic to put it
mildly from the outside looking in it
looked like the fame and fortune had
finally gone to og's heads like
somewhere along the way the underdogs
had turned into bullies but it's hard to
be mad if winners get carried away with
a little bit of smack talk at least it
would be if og would you know
win because they didn't make it into the
majors they were anything but a shoe-in
for ti-10 and og found themselves
battling through a last-chance regional
gauntlet to secure their spot and they
almost didn't make it top said he's out
of the game for good as that'll be it no
more backup here for og as tundra
they'll claim the victory gg called by
og as tundra will take this series 2-0
and they've secured themselves a ticket
to the grand final here fortunately for
og miracles are their specialty and they
made a comeback from the lower bracket
to win the grand finals rematch against
tundra dude you're about to knock them
out of qualification for ti sucks at
just no mercy no mercy at all
as one by one all of tundra falls og
doesn't even die and gg is called
og are going back to ti to defend their
title
obviously a large chunk of the dota 2
fandom we're happy to see og on the list
of teams at ti this year after achieving
everything dota has to offer it's
undeniable that og etched themselves
into esports history and into the hearts
of the community sebastian i mean
honestly i dedicate this tournament to
him
you're making me cry
but as the two-time world champions with
a shot at a third victory this year og's
members are obviously more heavily
scrutinized than the other top teams out
there their words and actions are held
to a standard that in all fairness might
be a lot to handle still gods are
expected to act accordingly and og's
antics have actually driven some of
their former fans into wishing they'd
lose just to dilute the toxic sense of
self-importance that the team seems to
have developed i take offense from teams
thinking
they can win against us
i actually take offense like it it
annoys me because i'd like to think that
after what has been done they should
they should realize that
this isn't realistic it's like maybe you
can but you
there's no way you believe that you can
that's not that's nonsense you should
believe that you can't and there's a
word in which yeah you might it's
possible that og have just been around
for so long and won so much that they've
become the anti-heroes of the scene the
giant that angry dota fans can pick on
without feeling like they're beating up
on the little guy after all it's easy to
cheer for the underdog and it's just as
easy to jump to a new underdog when one
presents itself when all is said and
done og's rise remains one of the most
inspiring cinderella stories in esports
history which is what makes their
transformation into the anti-heroes of
dota all the more exciting and that's
why if they win again and piss everyone
off it'll just be another incredible
chapter in their already unbelievable
story
[Music]
sorry that scared me i forgot you were
there
scared they're just like
that all right sebs here jesus thompson
got hot i don't know how to say this
how do you say this
yeah it's
it's it's a very good illinois i just
had no idea how i was supposed to say it